-Our next guest is the director
of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases
and the chief medical advisor
to President Joe Biden.
Here's Dr. Anthony Fauci!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. Thank you so much
for being here.
-Good to be with you, Jimmy.
-I appreciate this.
Where are you coming to us from?
From Washington?
-Yeah. Bethesda, Maryland,
just a little bit north
of Washington,
which is the headquarters
of the NIH.
-Ah. What foods are in Bethesda?
-Excuse me?
[ Laughter ]
-What foods you like
over there in Bethesda?
I thought you were
going to say D.C.
I was going to bring up a Ben's
Chili Bowl or something, but --
-[ Chuckles ]
Well, this is Maryland,
so crabs are in right now.
-Yeah, that's
what I'm talking about.
Yeah, alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm happy to be talking to you.
And it's almost bizarre
talking to you
because I'm talking to you
on the screen.
Normally, I'm watching you
on the screen talking to me,
so this is a little bizarre.
But I just wanted to thank you
for getting us through this --
or almost through this pandemic
and everything
you've done for us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because, gosh, you were there
every step of the way.
And you're really, like,
such a welcome face
to see on the screen
and someone that talks
with common sense.
We just all appreciated it.
And I just want to thank you,
on behalf of many Americans,
but definitely me.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
That's very nice of you.
Thank you.
-You have a new
administration now.
You have President Biden
and Kamala Harris.
How's it been going
working with them?
-Very well, actually.
You know, the issue here
is that everything we do
is based on science
and evidence and data.
And right now, the major thrust
of what we're doing
is implementing the vaccine plan
of getting people vaccinated,
which has really been
quite successful.
The numbers of infections
in this country
are going down substantially,
related to the fact
that we now have
about 50-plus percent
of the adult population
is fully vaccinated,
and about 64%
of the population of adults
have had at least one dose
of a two-dose regimen.
We want to hit 70%
of the adult population
vaccinated by July 4th.
Several states, about 14 states,
have already done that.
So we're really continuing
to emphasize the need
and the importance
to get vaccinated,
not only for your own
safety and health,
but for that of your family,
as well as
the community in general.
-That's why you're
on our show tonight.
We want to tell
all of our viewers out there
to get vaccinated
and get those numbers up.
We're very close.
I don't know if you --
Of course you heard the news.
But New York --
[ Laughter ]
Maybe I'm the first person
to tell you, but...
[ Laughter ]
...New York has hit 70%.
So, yeah. We're pretty --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, that's really --
Jimmy, that's really good news
for New York.
I mean, they have gotten
a good component
of their people vaccinated.
That means that they
will be able to open
and get things back to normal
in a much safer environment
than if there were very low
level of vaccinees.
So that's really the answer.
California's doing
the same thing.
Today, Governor Newsom
is just right on the same track
as New York, as the same thing.
So, if the people want to
get rid of constraints,
they want to get back to normal,
to do things that we all love,
get vaccinated,
and we'll get us there.
That's the answer
to all of this.
-That's right. Now, this --
Let's talk a little about,
the Biden administration
is calling this month
the National Month of Action.
-Right.
-Because we got to
get those numbers to 70%?
75$?
-Well, we want to go above that.
The goal, Jimmy, is to get us
to 70% of the adult population
vaccinated by the 4th of July.
But that doesn't mean
we want to stop there.
We want to keep going
beyond the 4th of July
and get more and more
people vaccinated,
because when you get
the overwhelming proportion
of the population vaccinated,
then there's no way that that
virus is going to resurge again.
I mean, that's the answer.
It has been traditionally,
with other infections, diseases,
and we're seeing now every place
that there has been an increase
in the percentage of vaccine,
there has been
a concomitant diminution
and decrease
in the number of infections.
So we really want
to go all the way.
We don't want
to stop at 75% or 80%.
We want to get as many people
vaccinated as we possibly can.
And that's what we're talking
about this Month of Action,
the march towards getting
more and more people vaccinated.
-Well, I hope everyone that
watches our show hasn't had one
thinks again and gets one
and gets vaccinated.
Let's get that number up.
And like you said,
don't stop at 70%.
Go past 70%.
And I -- Well,
speaking of not stopping,
you have not stopped, buddy.
And I got to say,
that's pretty awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't stop.
Don't stop. You're fantastic.
-I'm not going to stop, Jimmy,
don't worry.
-I appreciate it.
I appreciate it.
-Thank you.
-Dr. Anthony Fauci, everybody.